es ist mein geburtstag ein cousin barry
marge heute kann es regnen oder schneien
denn ich streue selber wie ein dorf
verdammter sonnenschein heute ist mein
geburtstag ich habe am 9
geburtstag okay ist nicht heute mein
geburtstag der ist am mittwoch aber
manchen geburtstags video mal wieder
hochladen ich weiß nicht wann ich das
letzte mal ein geburtstags video
hochgeladen
auch deswegen geburtstag hätte den
kommentar treiben dass ihr mich liebt
und er sieht das sehr wünschen ich würde
jetzt sagen das letzte teil nie kochen
videos jetzt nicht durch die decke
gegangen aber ich habe so lust ein teil
nie google zu machen also eine
dreistöckige torte in klein weil ich
einfach glaube dass es mega süß aussieht
wenn man so eine kleine dreistöckige
torte hat das habe ich noch nie vorher
gesehen und deswegen machen wir das
heute zu den bösen menschen gehöre die
dieses jahr noch mal in den urlaub
fahren habe ich vorgesorgt und zwar
wieder boden gekauft denn ich musste
heut backen und das müsste auskühlen und
das ist alles ein bisschen aufwendig und
ich wollte ein bisschen einfach meine
zweite kamera hat euch letzte mal
gefragt wegen machen wir das heute
wieder und ich glaube es ist ganz gut
wenn man so einen namen blick hat
schritt nummer eins wir bereiten unseren
kuchen vor übrigens habe ich für dieses
video meine ganze abstellkammer
geplündert und alles mögliche an deko
rausgeholt ich bin mir noch nicht ganz
sicher über den look von der torte aber
irgendwas wird schon rauskommt und ich
werde nur ein boden verwenden müssen
denn es ist ja kein mensch früher aber
den rest ein dann kann ich ihn immer
rausholen wenn ich noch mal eine torte
machen möchte ist ein krümel und kurz
das weiß ich glaube ihr euch erinnert
aber bei dem torten battle gegen kelly
habe ich einen wiener boden selber
gemacht und bestimmt schon längst selbst
gemacht besser aber es ist so ich dachte
ich hey es ist nämlich wichtig hilfe
anzunehmen denn sie
angeboten wird und das ist die beste
hilfe zum glücklichen super nett und
habe einfach keks ausstecher in
sämtlichen größen und die werde ich auch
jetzt verwenden drei stufen für die drei
standorte und den schneiden wir erst mal
aus hatte auch überlegt so eine richtig
fette geile torte zu machen
da ich aber meinen geburtstag ja nicht
mit vielen leuten feiern kann wollte ich
jetzt keine torte machen die ich nicht
aufessen können und dann brauche ich
sondern mittleren dadurch brauchen wir
zwei von allen damit es ein bisschen
hochgeht
ja definitiv
[Musik]
wow kuchen reste niemals wegschmeißen
ihr könnt daraus leckere desserts machen
in einem glas mit ein bisschen joghurt
creme r perso so oder so es ist super
lecker oder er ist es halt sofort fertig
und das ist mein tutorial wie eine
kleine torte macht da wir alle eine gute
erdbeertorte lieben habe ich noch
erdbeeren gefunden
aus diesem jahr aus deutschland und die
sehen richtig gut aus mein gott stellt
euch mal vor sylt des jahres falls ja
wir brauchen die zwischen krems für
unsere einzelnen stationen natürlich
machen wir eine schöne vanillecreme ist
doch klar was wird alles wieder so tiny
wir brauchen so kleine portionen ist
schöner sich diesmal sowie nicht kleine
portion machen muss mathematik 60 gramm
weiße schokolade und 40 gramm sahne
dampf machen wir die vanille creme zum
befüllen dass wir die sahne aufkochen
das ding ist ich war so verwirrt und
wusste überhaupt nicht was für eine
füllung ich mache weil es gibt butter
krems es gibt keine ahnung es gibt alles
mögliche wie man so eine torte füllen
kann aber seine schokocreme es immer
geahnt und die schokolade dazu geben das
ist unsere mischung hinterließ vanille
extrakt nicht vergessen den habe ich
fast vergessen
und jetzt brauchen wir so ein
trotzdem co
das war schon zu viel und in der zeit in
der das abkühlt könnt ihr den chance
nutzen das team und nicht das und ihr
kind essen könnte empfehlung des hauses
das vegane kimchi wir brauchen aber
nicht nur die füllung sondern auch die
garage außenrum die kommt vor creme und
so damit das so schön glatt ist weil
sonja sehr krümelig ist und dann bei der
buttercreme könnte das alles ein
bisschen blöd aussehen deswegen fragen
wir jetzt sally noch mal wie das
verhältnis ist ja gar nicht ein viertel
der 50 gramm sahne und 150 gramm weiße
schokolade wie muss mich auch unbedingt
anfangen mehr mit veganem backen zu
beschäftigen
dadurch dass ich das so selten gemacht
habe habe ich einfach keine skills und
ich fühle mich immer wohler wenn ich die
normalen produkte benutzen wie immer
aber es gibt ja gute alternative
vielleicht mache ich das machen wir die
schmelz zum beginn leute es gibt nichts
besseres einfach so etwas kann über
weihnachten sprechen dachte wirklich ein
bisschen zu früh aber es ist ja nicht so
dass ich nicht schon adventskalender
unboxing vor paar tagen hochgeladen
haben mit der zeit in der die ganze show
sich im kühlschrank unsere kleine bäche
wieder an meiner schule jetzt gerade
extrem laut an meiner tür
für einen klar
dittmann sind genug die krimis fest
geworden
haben wir ein bisschen marmelade oder
vanille marmelade so dann nehme ich was
von der creme kommt die erb der hak kyu
[Musik]
hahahaha eine frage habe ich aber an
euch glaubt ihr ich sollte mir ein
kameramann holen manchmal überlege ich
auch das mit einem kameramann das
natürlich auch geil wer also das drehen
könnte man mal schreiben ob ihr euch das
gefallen
du siehst wir können um das mittelfeld
und ich kleinste
[Musik]
so und jetzt schmieren wir noch die
rückseite von dem boden und deckel drauf
und sandwich nummer drei okay leute
genau schützt ist gering dafür krempel
hier sogar meine er mit nokia die krimis
fest genug dass wir weitermachen können
hier ist unsere garage und sie ist
perfekt
ich liebe es wie ich immer so komplett
in so eine stille gerate wenn ich mich
konzentrieren muss aber eine gute
konsistenz hat es eigentlich mache ich
ja patisserie gerade hier ist so klar
hin es ist auch anstrengend weil es so
kleine pause auseinander
auch wenn die speicherkarte voll ist und
das ist nicht aufnehmen kann da rufen
kühlschrank und mich in die klapse bei
machen jetzt eine buttercreme mit
puderzucker mutter ganz easy wir wollen
es nicht kompliziert machen welche farbe
es für eine torte gut nämlich wenn sie
so kitschig mache somit so hängen denn
ja mit geld und so eine rosa man mit
gelb und pink
ok dann brauchen wir pro tag und da
kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen
produktionen schlagen wir sie auch vor
schon wieder sind starken arm auf diese
farbe vertraulich und hier haben wir ja
das ist eine buddha creme
damit können wir unsere toto bestreichen
man wenn man in dem es mit der farbe
rein so eine messerspitze wird
hoffentlich ausreichend
aber das müssen wir jetzt so schnell ein
gefährt noch einmal die ist wunderschön
die stufen werden schwierig das ist halt
blöd gewesen von mir nun bin ich ehrlich
die schon aufeinander zu stellen
[Musik]
aber nie zauberkugel vergessen was diese
bat videos doch immer lange dauert auch
wenn stylist dauert lange corps an
ferien dieser stelle ja ja ja jetzt
zweite schicht leute acht wenn nicht
besser er das ist jetzt wirklich feine
form besser wird's nicht ich bekomme
einen nervenzusammenbruch und ich war
schon gelb oder creme aufgeschlagen hat
mich ein bisschen dass ich doch noch
nehmen sollen
die speicherkarte straße aus nein
scheiße
[Musik]
überall
danke das ist ein wunderschöner tag also
und das muss jetzt da drauf deco ist
schon fast werden jetzt kommen zum
doppel in die saiten griff
[Musik]
denn gerne
natürlich lasse ich diese farbe böse
buttercreme nicht schlecht werden mehr
pink mehr p ich hoffe ich mache nichts
dümmeres benutzt jetzt so pink rot rot
meistens eine zweite kette ich glaube
dass soweit ich glaube sie kommt jetzt
erst mal ein kühlschrank damit ihr
nichts passiert was ich begonnen habe
[Applaus]
ich habe ein paar stunden dran gesessen
das hat ein bisschen gedauert aber ich
muss sagen wie es wirklich schön
geworden da sind geburtstagstorte ist
bevor sie komplett weggeschmolzen ist
happy birthday to me happy birthday to
me das ist wirklich das traurigste sich
selber happy birthday zu singen alles
gute presse das muss wünschen
jetzt können wir die anschneiden ein
kleinster lacht aber ich habe versteckt
gefunden eine kleine zugabe ich habe die
ordner ein geburtstagskuchen anschneiden
es ist so wie es ist
bitte bitte bitte bitte und jetzt
stellen wir uns das allerwichtigste
frage wie schmeckt einem winzig kleine
geburtstagstorte wahrscheinlich da eine
normale geburtstagstorte nur in winzig
[Musik]
lecker jemals gemacht habe zwar ohne
willst du musst kommen ich bin fertig
durchprobieren bombay gott es ist wohl
ein stück torte anbieten ich bitte darum
sicherheitsleute zwischen probiert man
kennt dann hast du jetzt mal ein
richtiges stück abschneiden war es
wirklich
können wir sagen wir haben eine ganze
torte gegessen
für den combo vermögen
[Musik]
ich bin emotional noch nicht bereit
diese torte haben im ding doch die war
so viel aber das war so filigrane arbeit
viele green viele krimis ordentlicher
wissenschaftler so leute immer wieder
gefallen wir hatten daumen nach oben